superhero movies are obviously fun to
watch their continued success at the box
office is proof enough that audiences
get a kick out of them
maybe it's because they've got a little
something for everyone plenty of action
high-stakes human drama and even a few
laughs laced into the mix as it happens
there are often even more laughs during
filming than there are on screen it's
probably a combination of the set being
a high-tech playground and everyone
getting punchy from long shooting days
but whatever the case it makes for some
really silly and amusing superhero movie
bloopers daredevil he may be blind but
daredevil has other abilities and
heightened senses that make up for it
not among those abilities it would seem
it's a minion over the sky and its many
creatures as Ben Affleck discovered
while filming a fight scene in 2003 s
daredevil while trying to perform his
well rehearse stunt choreography he
found himself unable to quite pull it
off because the birds that were supposed
to make the scene look cool just kept
running into him I don't know what
Superman it's a risky business to employ
child actors in big-budget movies we're
saying the right thing at the right time
is kind of important in a scene from
1978 Superman Jonathan and Martha Kent's
have discovered toddler Superman and
other bating what to do with the
presumably lost or orphaned boy that's
when the three-year-old thespian forgets
he's supposed to be acting is we are
going to find this boys proper family oh
she hasn't got any not around here
anyway tiger
spider-man 3 spider-man isn't cool
or at least Peter Parker spider-man's
mild-mannered alter ego isn't cool he's
certainly no Bruce Wayne he's lacking
the Dark Knight suave self-possession
that's why this blooper reel in which
spider-man 3 star Tobey Maguire is
completely enabled to stop laughing
while filming a normal life building
mundane scene almost feels like it's in
character having a laughing fit in a
restaurant is so goofy it seems like
something young awkward Peter Parker
would do we got it we got a control
action hi Peter hi Ant Man of course are
going to be some bloopers riffs outtakes
and cutscenes from a superhero movie
starring Paul Rudd he's a gifted veteran
comic actor and he brought a sense of
fun and play to 2015's ant-man a movie
that at the time was based around one of
Marvel's less mainstream characters rod
who usually stars in wild comedies and a
small dramas can't help but reflect on
how we've suddenly wearing a superhero
suit in a mega budget action movie you
won't be cousin to me don't yellow knee
I'm here to Deadpool the dialogue is so
self referential and self-deprecating
and the Ryan Reynolds has such a witty
off-the-cuff delivery that almost the
entirety of 2016 Deadpool feels like it
could have been improvised
that's not to say that Reynolds didn't
improvise on set because he did a lot
one particular moment though seems to
have caught his co-stars complete
off-guard after all it's in the middle
of a fight scene in the back of a
speeding car not generally the type of
place for a person breaks out into an
old Kenny Rogers song no and Boulder
nowhere to park
normally and Aroo spider-man Willem
Dafoe is one of the finest dramatic
actors of his or any generation but that
doesn't mean he doesn't like to have fun
as evidenced by his decision to play the
Green Goblin in 2002 spider-man he also
likes to have fun riffing on set when
filming what's supposed to be a dramatic
tension building moments in which the
villains aiyah - spider-man threatens to
boil over the foe started making a lot
of angry noises and then some other
noises guardians of the galaxy there are
a few ways for an actor to react if
their scene partner messes up they can
remain silent go back to their mark and
try again
they can also laugh uproariously or they
can stay in character and remove the gag
on the set of guardians of the galaxy
Michael Rooker went with the latter
option
he was cargo and you go go hopped on you
watch this right off the set
yes I can come on I'm going to do it
again Jake asked to Chloe grace Moretz
is a young actress but she's been
working a long time and was already a
seasons professional when she made
2013's kick-ass - reprising her role a
self-made superhero hits girl in one
I'll take Moritz delivers a line with
such conviction that nobody but the
script a supervisor would have even
known she'd muster wrong x-men the first
x-men movie was released in 2000 long
before the Marvel Cinematic Universe was
up and running with its various
spin-offs team-ups sequels and
crossovers before that superhero movies
were generally standalone Affairs
featuring just one comic property so
it's really silly and surprising when a
guy dressed as a certain web slinger
sneaks into the line of pursuit
a powered mutants are ready to fight
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love thing
[Music]